okay my question is for Liam what was
your reaction to Harry Styles calling
these phallic gringo during his SNL
monologue last night well not even it
plead the fifth yet
that's Liam Payne weighing in on Harry
Styles recent dig at Zayn Malik on
Saturday Night Live you know I think
it's just a funny joke at the end of the
day I mean obviously you know Zane's
circumstances for leaving were his own
and it's a different situation for all
of us I suppose we deal with it in a
different way so I mean I thought was
quite funny let's rewind back in
November Harry was the host and the
musical guest on SNL I'm not a boy band
anymore
I'm in a man now I was in a band called
One Direction how crazy would it be if
they were here tonight
well that not during his opening
monologue the cherry singer through some
not so subtle shade at his former One
Direction bandmate Zayn who famously
left the band back in 2015 to kick off
his own solo career I love those guys
and my brothers Louie
[Music]
Ringo of course Harry was referring to
Ringo Starr who was the first to leave
another very famous band in the 60s a
little band called The Beatles ever
heard of them anyway 1d split for good
in 2016 announcing a quote indefinite
hiatus since then all the members of the
band have launched their own solo
careers including Liam who stopped by
watch what happens live with Andy Cohen
on Thursday to promote his new album LP
one do an hour gonna live forever
[Music]
he also opened up about seeing Harry for
the first time in years you recently
said you ran into Harry Styles for the
first time in three years what was the
nature of your conversation that night
um we spoke about a number of things we
hadn't seen shows of a three years
lecture I hadn't seen him once and we
hadn't spoken or anything so it was good
to see him it's he was pretty much the
same boy that I left him we spoke about
kids and Happiness and all sorts and
then there was this Liam
which member of One Direction do you
think is the most well endowed I'll have
to say myself well I'm gonna say me okay
but let's circle back to the Harry of it
all they're runnin came just after Liam
gave some kind of shady quotes to the
face magazine about Harry he slammed his
high fashion wardrobe and called himself
the Antichrist version of the watermelon
sugar singer quote there's so much
mystery around who he's become I was
looking at some pictures of him the
other day and I just thought I don't
know what more I'd say to him other than
hello and how are you but I guess they
did have some things to talk about which
tracks with what Liam told et back in
2017
about running into his old bandmates
when you see someone they haven't seen
for ages and you become the same person
you were when you with I don't know it's
very interesting as for Harry he
recently sat down with Apple musics Zane
Lowe and opened up about the early days
with the band it was like a picture of
us that had been taken from when we were
at the show and it was like the first
picture of us as the five of us we were
like living in this little bungalow all
of us together to like practice we'd
heard this picture was being put in the
paper so we were like I was gonna be the
paper
that's crazy we're all just like sitting
staring at the paper and like passing
around if anything we're like let me see
it let me see how cute is that I'm still
holding out for a One Direction reunion
please please PLEASE of course you can
count on et to bring you all the latest
on Harry Liam Niall Louie and Ringo
immune Zayn so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Hallie Stevens see you soon
[Music]